it's like they say that they would love
to be with someone like the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam they would
love to be like with someone like but he
lived in poverty when a man is killing
you to a woman she hates it she's
disgusted by it it's like drinking too
much um honey and all this kind of stuff
it makes you sick the lack of romance
from their husbands they feel bored with
their partner it shouldn't feel like a
janeza when you get married that's it
it's doomsday most men just think that
if they are providing financially then
everything else is not really important
giving you a flower does not do anything
for their self-esteem but seeing more
money in their account that does
something for their self-esteem if
you're unjust and you let your mum
humiliate your wife she's gonna lose
respectful you know my mom is looking at
her husband in the grave there's no five
foot one five foot six nothing you've
got to see you've got to see what your
kids of your wife is you've got to see
your creative person what does she like
to do and then try and find an Islamic
Avenue where she can actually do those
things so she doesn't feel like she's
always suppressing some the younger the
guy is the more immature he's going to
be and the older he is is the more
mature he's gonna I know some women who
literally have never received not one
flower from their husbands and he was
giving me some information about how the
younger guys are failing at their
marriages because they're working too
much when we say that marriage is going
to complete half your Dean it doesn't
mean that you're half empty already
foreign
net is raising funds to establish a
Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Savage for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah for your donation you
and Charlotte click the link and donate
what you can
assalamu alaikum what happened to your
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another episode of The Bitter
truth before I start I want to praise
Allah the most merciful the most trust
or Praises glory and gratitude belong to
him and today's topic is a very
interesting topic
um and I think it's a topic that should
have been discussed long long time about
alhamdulillah but we've got around today
basic rules of the bitter truth we've
got the bitter buzzers if you disagree
with anybody
um press it you'll have one and a half
minutes nobody can interrupt you you can
press it only once and please just
refrain from backbiting slandering and
you know have Basics
we have amazing panels here
alhamdulillah as we know all the time
the champions in the building Gabriel
Hayden
long time I actually haven't actually I
haven't seen it for a while that's right
as a brother I miss you thank you may
Allah bless you I love your uh you know
your presence here in the show
alhamdulillah you have so much to offer
and I learned as well and we have our
honorable sisters may Allah bless them
inshallah sister
neslan we've got sister dopamine we've
got sister Amira may Allah she's come
here today with her husband and we've
got sister fahima so
let's get straight into it inshallah
it's been a long day uh the topic I had
today is I think I think it's a very
important one which is basically how
ah
a Muslim husband how should how do we
Define a good Muslim husband like in a
nutshell
what makes a good Muslim husband show us
that from the sisters because today
we're grilling the brothers so I think
we should start from the sisters because
the sisters if they if you can tell us
what do you define as a good Muslim
husband then we'll come to what Islam
says but what is your expectations what
is it that you would say okay this man
is a good Muslim husband this man is a
good Muslim man let's start off with
I stop
we're gonna have the mic close please
um in my personal experience yeah I
think what makes a good Muslim husband
is that when the wife needs his support
he's there and when she's going through
turmoil or trials he supports her in
that time if he doesn't show support in
that time for me it equates to a bad man
because and again once you've had
children with that man as well depending
on how he is with the children also for
me is an example of a good or a bad man
and that's just based off experience but
yeah I'll start off with that just
support and providing basically very
good
um personally I would say that it's
someone who strives to fulfill his role
as much as he can
within the Realms of Islam and what's
defined in our guides in Islam
um but obviously everybody goes through
a journey and we're not perfect we have
days where we struggle but I think it
the main thing is that Strife to fulfill
um what we've been ordained to be and
behave as within a marriage so
that's for me like the probably the main
thing because the the trying Factor
um but also obviously I agree with a
sister
um actually playing out all the things
that we suppose he's supposed to be
anyway um such as being a provider and I
think that's quite a big Topic in modern
times
um and yeah being someone that's
sensitive in the sense where he
um tries to understand that you know the
wife is different to him and therefore
he has to be flexible in the way he that
he is to adapt to feminine needs in the
same way that a wife would for masculine
needs so yeah that's my opinion okay
um for me I think uh
a husband is supposed to be able to lead
his family
um in obviously with his children be
able to teach his children guide his
children but with his wife
um
communication is key
I think
if my husband is supposed to be able to
teach me to to enable me to be a
critical thinker
um to guide me to protect me to lead
also to provide for the family and to be
my companion to be my peace
um
as well as myself being his and not to
shout I think a lot of people do
get
communication very wrong and I think
that is the major thing but also to
um push me to be a better person and a
better Muslim if my husband's not able
to keep reminding me of my Dean because
you know in Islam you complete half of
your Deen when you marry your spouse so
if he's not able to push me to towards
Jannah and who's pushing me towards
jahannam then that's a big problem
um so yeah so he has to be my ultimate
peace guide and companion for life
inshallah you know
okay just a flamer
um I think I have a little bit of a
different take
um I think we have too much expectation
from men and women on each other and I
think we need to build ourselves first
because when we live and when we die we
are accountable by ourselves and I think
in this day and age we feel entitled and
we think that the other person has to
lead us you know to make us do certain
things when actually it's our own
responsibility and if the other person
is not in that particular way it doesn't
mean that that should or shouldn't
influence us and I know that a lot of
people can get influence but that just
shows their level of Iman strength
weakness whatever you want to call it
because I'm quite tough when it comes to
things like this and I just think that
there's a lot of expectation for women
on men and men and women and we are
encouraged to be married young and I'm
sorry a lot of young men do not have
emotional intelligence at that age they
don't have the commitment even if they
think they know the word they don't know
what responsibility is and even long
term it has to be nurtured in time it
depends on family the socio-economic
background it depends on so many
different you know factors that we have
to consider but I think when we're
trying to get married it's all about the
other person trying to give us well
we're not even there ourselves saying
what are we going to put at the table
what do we offer how are we emotionally
in a particular way so that at the end
of the day if they're there yes it's a
great support it's a great reminder but
I don't need that to be a proper Muslim
or a proper person or a female I just
need someone who I can you know be
myself and obviously grow and learn with
them that's what I think personally
because I think there's a lot of you
know
expectation on the other person and oh
they complete me oh you know they need
to be a particular way to Help Me Grow I
can do that for myself complete and you
but you complete half your Dean like
complete half of your Dean when you do
get married but that's the Institute of
it no but I'm saying like when it comes
to personal development that's a side to
the topic because the topic is
how how is a Muslim man going to be a
good husband you know so it's about
companionship it's not about the self
work when you come into a unity and into
a marriage it's about how do we evolve
and stay in that marriage together so
that we work together so it's really
important can I give a balance which I
think you both are speaking maybe past
each other it's very important what you
said is the famous very mature outlook
on it which all of you guys as well what
you said is for example when Brothers
come and say I'm going to compete half
my Dean I go uh what that means is
you're half already full you're half
empty yeah you have to be half full so
it's completely you're half empty you're
in prayer you don't do your Basics so
how are you completing your dinner you
don't even have the so the point is what
sister famous I think is trying to say
is that basically and I think it's very
important to have a Reliance on Allah
because if you come and say oh I'm going
to marry this person so they'll make me
better they might not be so basically
what she's saying is don't rely on that
fix yourself first which says the you
can please half your Dean fix the first
part which is you and relies on you then
if you get married it can be that she
fixes you or she can destroy you or vice
versa so I think you both are right just
coming to the promise brother Gabriel
inshallah and then from there onwards
um what would you define as a good
because we've heard a lot of stuff I
mean the sisters can give us a whole
list of what is a good Muslims but as a
man coming from a man's perspective what
do you define as a a Muslim a good
Muslim husband why am I being called
Gabriel I mean sorry I'm sorry just just
there's some context I stepped six hours
in the morning I had boxing
um
okay not like you do four hours okay 44
hours you come to my gym yeah no okay no
it's not so I can forgive me man
it's the English version
um well obviously
how to be a good husband or or what is a
good husband is obviously the example of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that's Allah's mentioned he's he's the
he's the best of examples he's the best
of creation
said himself that the best amongst your
those who are the best your wives and
I'm the best
um to my wife's so the closest to the
Sunday is that is the is the way to be
the best husband but
and so obviously that requires a man to
obviously know
um his messenger
to know the message that he came with
because
she described him as the Quran what the
Quran is is what the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam is so of course for a
Muslim to be a good husband he has to be
fairly grounded in his Islam
um but in today's time we we live in
such a a crazy world there's so many
challenges that the man has to face
every day
um and he needs a lot
psychologically he needs a lot
financially
he needs a lot spiritually
he needs so much subhanallah
um and so sometimes for a man to be able
to be that
he needs a very understanding wife
and he's a very empathetic wife he needs
a woman because you see they say behind
every great man is a great woman
and women play a big part in who a man
is of course a man has to himself be
solid because a woman relies on him but
the prophet salallahu relied so much
also on
his other wives you know when when he
was when he came and he said right cover
me cover me
like you know it was her that was his
backbone and and his support
and nowadays it's like women want to
come into a man's life when he's already
that was established and
it's like they say that they would love
to be with someone like the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam they would
love to be like with someone like Ali
radialah but they lived in poverty
so this is it's just a lot of Kalam
they're not bad
life it's just it's just Kalam but and
so what what ends up happening isn't
that look I thought about before having
this discussion what angle do I want to
take do I want to do I want to focus a
lot on the brothers
do I want to focus on this this is about
trying to be as balanced as possible
but I want the women to understand that
if you want to have a good husband
because a man usually gets married
without wanting problems there are some
problematic individuals out there for
sure there's troublemakers they just
have something wrong with them but most
men when they get married
they don't get married with the
intention of leaving and they just want
peace and I feel like today one of the
big issues that we have when it comes to
marriage is a lack of gratitude for men
and a lack of gratitude for women one of
our one of our beloved teachers
Institute he mentioned that the the
sound the fundamental basis for marital
problems is a lack of gratitude
that's that's like the the ground under
which any problem is built upon is a
lack of gratitude and there are men that
go out every single day and they strive
and they try and they go to work on the
tubes there's naked women in front of
them
literally so on the tubes in in the
posters there's naked women in front of
them in the summer there's women walking
around everywhere naked and he's a good
man he's a loyal man he's going to work
he's handling his business he's not out
here
cheating and doing this and doing that
but he's coming home to just problems
and stress and he can't find any peace
eventually you might have married a good
man with a whole load of potential but
because of the issues he's dealing with
you've actually derailed him you've
actually caused him you've actually
pushed him like the sister described
what she needs from her husband someone
who would lead her towards Jannah
they're sometimes leading them the
husband the opposite direction and vice
versa obviously this works this works
both ways 100 yes
very important um but so to you what
would you define as a good Muslim
husband what is a good life what is the
thing characteristics what are the
things that he should do that we say
this is a good Muslim husband the debate
the basics like is providing
um loyalty
um what's the definition of loyalty
because sometimes have a definition
where yeah there's not yeah that that
wouldn't fall under disloyalty at all in
the slides if I'm gonna be completely
honest with you
when I Define loyalty in the most
important man I'm saying someone who
doesn't commit adultery essentially I
know loyalty goes deep in that yes
voted Sean when he's taking care of his
family
that's how man's loyalty is if he's
going and working and providing that's
how you know for man is loyal if he's
going and providing and protecting
that's his loyalty should be measured so
they have a different man it's a part of
it's a part of loyalty I guess you're
being loyal in the sense of fulfilling
that right but I think when when we
generally in our society when we think
about loyalty it's always to do with
intimacy and and opposite agenda
um I'm not a big fan of women
um divorcing their husbands due to due
to school boy errors and to communicate
and stuff like that sometimes men are
going through stuff they are not happy
at home or they're feeling their
self-esteem is low and men can do some
really stupid things so if a woman of
course obviously you guys know I do
counseling if a woman comes to me with
issues like that I'll always encourage
her to to be forbearing and not even to
go through her husband's phone to even
come come across these these things it's
not it's not wise sorry because you're a
counselor I actually really
there's other cultures that do
premarital counseling and I think
we need this more in our communities
it's really pretty much because you have
like these little communication issues
that or just like you said issues with
the man himself where he has Schoolboy
errors that could just have that
conversation
um that could save marriages I don't I
don't think that the Muslim couple
should should need pre-marital
counseling I really think that the
parents of fathers and daughters need to
be schooling their kids and I actually
asked on Instagram the question
how many of you male and female has has
your mom or dad ever
educated you on where it is to be
married what to expect from a woman
like it's a dad if a dad who knows what
marriage is like who knows what women is
like and a man down and explain to
him yo this is what to expect it doesn't
happen this need this needs to happen
because if because the way women are no
offense
most men are going to marry a woman that
she he's gonna think she's imagining
like she's he's literally married the
worst of the worst when she's just there
are cultural differences so nice some
cultures some parents are not able to
translate that advice to us like who are
born and raised well inshallah we're
moving away from that because that's a
must it should start from the parents
and also can we stick to the topic
please which is how to be a good Muslim
husband can we also have the brother
here inshallah
please
first of all I would like to thank your
brother Ali to invite me to this panel
and may Allah bless you and all the
brothers and sisters who make uh this uh
uh
initiative possible and may Allah bless
all your work and the dedication and the
may Allah bless you
uh to answer the question of for my
little experience of 16 years of
marriage for me
above the basics of being a good
provider caretaker and someone who can
listen
uh I think that a good husband is
somebody who can work on himself because
the the main problems that happens here
in in this day and age is the the lack
of ability to to make compromise
most of the time people are I think they
are logic and okay I'm right this is
wrong I should be this is not about
being right or wrong subhanallah we say
that we know that women can be emotional
and they have been compared to a rib and
they who try to to loosen up it will
break so don't try to to apply your
logic on everything and um do it for
Allah both Cuts Allah in the equation
and for example in arguing you say okay
you know what I'm going
true to apologize even though I'm I'm
100 right for the sake of Allah
try to learn to to compromise I think
it's it's very underrated that it's the
most important thing to my eyes
okay that's a 16-year marriage man
talking right there man you need to keep
the mic right here bro yeah what would
you say is
um like what is it Islam saying in the
sense where this is a good Muslim
husband
well I mean I think a lot of it has
actually already been covered to be
honest
um like the protection the provision
obviously
that this is a Kia actually uh in how to
be a good husband which is that men are
maintainers and Protectors of women
because of uh what Allah has given one
day has given the other and because of
what they spend and the spending thing
is actually quite a big thing because
the prophet saws
the worst thing because we would talk
about what man has to have but this
Hadith is actually very critical because
it's telling you what a man can't have
children says that the worst thing in
the in a man is
very stinginess if he's a stingy person
that's one of the worst things a man can
exhibit number one number two is
which is your account
so the one of the two worst things or
vices that you can exhibit as a man
according to him
yeah it's the opposite in a sense right
so Yanni what you cannot be is a person
who's stinging the first advice I'd give
to my son
gets my doors as well no problem
yeah but I will tell him look I mean
don't ever be afraid to
spend on your wife and kids
you know what I mean because a lot of
people they are afraid of this aspect
like you you you're I meet people that
are budgeting with their wives and I
find it very disgusting actually to be
honest with you like you've got to be
very generous with your wife
and you should never think okay I've
spent this much on you and this kind of
behavior now don't even speak about it
you know you've got to give up even if
she's being ungrateful would you say for
example in a sense where yeah even it
should be ungrateful unless she's being
mashes that's a different story though
rebellious that's because then you can't
reward that kind of behavior that's a
different issue but I'm saying like even
if she's being ungrateful that's your
thing you're given and you'll you'll
find that just by being generous with
your wife
that a lot of the resentment that she
has from your behavior towards her
actually it goes down
it's not about like materialism and
stuff everybody like even a child a
woman everybody likes money and gifts
and stuff it's not Haram so the prophet
sallam was very as much as he could be
generous of his wives I mean there's a
beautiful Hadith
uh actually in buhari is mentioned
wives at the same time
and there was it was they were living a
hard life because it was impoverished he
went to a Jewish man he gave the his
spear for like Bali and wheat and stuff
like that so he can give it to his wife
his spear is what he'd be using in war
he used that as collateral they used it
in the Book of Life That's the extent to
which she was eager to provide for his
wives so that's the first thing and
being a coward there's no
come back from that like for example if
someone disrespects your wife
and you are you cannot defend your
wife's rights
then you then there's almost no comeback
if you're unjust and you let your mum
humiliate your wife she's gonna lose
respect for you because a lot of in some
Continental culture you have that you
have a lot of like yeah let's talk about
these mommy's voice because yeah you do
have that like so he'll let his mom
abuse the the woman yeah as if she is in
charge of she got no Islamic right upon
her at all and so he can't be just in
that situation so being a cow
effectively being a talent that is being
empowered so the two worst things about
it that's number one number two is I
would say on the on the point I actually
agree with for him in a sense
and God be careful with like
this idea this notion of depending on
yourself I agree with the idea
that a Muslim man or woman this is the
same advice I'd give my son as I would
give my daughter which is when we say
religion or when we say that marriage is
going to complete half your Dean it
doesn't mean that you're half empty
already you're Integris as you're coming
in as as a man or as a woman and the
Hadith that really sticks out to me in
that basis is the prophet saw said that
and listen um
the shutoff of this ummah the Dignity of
the honor the badge of honor of this
ummah is
and he said that it's Isaac it's my is
self-dependency when someone is
self-sufficient this doesn't actually
differentiate between men and women you
know so in a sense like if that you
cannot allow this man to dictate how
you're feeling
like for example if he decides to leave
you
oh if you decide to end the relationship
your relationship will Allah has to be
strong enough that you can enjoy that
that's not going to end you it's not
going to destroy you okay yeah but
that's what sister famous says yeah
so that's I do believe that that's now
the strongest thing a man can have I
think both men and women should have
this by the way
like because the Hadith indications
are men and women yeah but the strongest
thing a man can have as a Muslim husband
is his power to walk away
it's not his divorce it's not his second
wife it's not hiding the wife it's not
the other things we spoke about
previously why are you looking at me but
no I'm just saying it's the strongest
card that he can play is leaving the
woman there's nothing stronger than that
you know what can I just add on that
yeah I think wallahi if a man because
I'm I'm trying to understand the
Dynamics and with this show with the
guess what like I learned so much that
it benefits my marriage yeah may Allah
bless you guys well it actually it
abandons my marriage if a man is a good
man if he's a good Muslim husband but
while I I genuinely believe this because
sometimes what men do is like the wife
and this that okay good yeah whatever
man this today's episode is about
brothers if a man is good to his wife
look if he's praying he's doing his Deen
Etc staying away from major sins not
going and talking to girls and none of
that you know because that's very very
it's it's
traumatizing as well
if a man can do that and he's loving to
his kids yeah when like for example like
when she needs him he's there I don't
think that woman would ever leave that
man
like I don't believe that even for
example if he wants to implement certain
stuff that gives him such a power in the
sense where not that you're doing it for
the power but I believe that like you
said this biggest power would be for
example if he was to leave because of a
Disobedience she would come to a sense
and say you know what this actually is a
good man I self internalized and
realized I'm wrong I don't want to lose
it just to add to that if if you feel
like if you leave your wife if you if
you go somewhere if you leave her she's
not going to come to you
then I think that you should leave her I
know it sounds bad but there's no
connection there there's no there's no
love oh if you believe if you leave and
there's no response there's no response
from her like for me this I'm going to
tell my son look he's almost the
following listen my son I will son of
mine yeah yeah
oh my son yeah oh my boy I'm gonna say
listen this is what you need to do
before you get into marriage yeah you
need to be you need to psychologically
Prime yourself so that if at any point
you feel like she's crossed the
boundaries or the thresholds or anything
like that you can take a decision
to leave and that won't Crush you won't
destroy you if you can't put yourself in
a position where you can leave that wife
that particular wife and on the flip
side my doors I'm going to tell them if
he leaves you you can you have to be
able to
deal with it yourself and manage you
have to have that internal mechanism
within yourself you don't become bitter
yeah this is so this is very important
what your strongest power is your power
to walk away as a husband it takes
discipline to do that as well it does
because men are clingy like it's not
just women that the worst you can be
with I think that you know like we talk
about um the topic of discussion today
is how to be a good husband you have to
be affectionate
of course you have to be affectionate
all right so now this is a key pillar of
a marriage affection key pillar if you
leave it the woman might hate you
actually yes like if you don't
compliment her and tell her how good she
looks uh physically yeah in the mornings
whatever time it doesn't matter so if
you don't do this bit if you don't tell
her like how good she looks and whatever
if you don't have that you're nothing
you're not a man you might as well just
leave because in about six months or a
year's time she might lose interest in
you she's going to look for that from
somewhere else
I believe that I personally believe that
if you're not providing any level of
affection but the flip side of it which
a lot of brothers make a mistake of as
well is smothering the woman
that said this is one of the six main
reasons why people get divorced it's
called partner Pursuit it's called
clinginess when a man is killing you to
a woman she hates it she's disgusted by
it it's like drinking too much uh honey
and all this kind of stuff it makes you
sick it's so true you know I hear I hear
I hear of stories yeah on this please
yes but I think in a woman's fitter it's
she is I want to see she's built to
chase but she like I hear the stories
there was a story I heard of a brother
who's whose wife actually cheated on him
like a Muslim woman yeah by the way yeah
hijabi yeah I'm not saying I'm not
saying that well I'm just saying in
general uh so and and I said I asked him
I said like for example can you tell me
a bit but I don't understand Dynamics
how did it score wrong he said bro I
gave everything she wants and I was like
saying
stop there when you say I gave her
everything she wants brother this is the
biggest now what do I mean by that it
has to be a fine balance bro there has
to be a time when you say no you have
your Authority do you get it the moment
you start behaving off what do you want
about that yeah you go everything bro
it's human nature even if we do it
amongst Brothers if I was like
everything that I wanted and hijab was
like yes yes yes well we have a
disagreements we have arguments here
this this is what makes it but what
would you guys say you've heard hijab
um let's touch upon like we've talked
all about how should how to be a good
Muslim husband but what about these
mommy's boys what about what is the
biggest what would you say the biggest
contentions a lot of sisters have when
it comes to their husbands because I
know since they have a lot of
contentions we just want to know some of
them please top three please we move on
to the Mommy's boy I just really want to
make a point on the fact of the giving
being generous to your wife I think I've
received a lot of DMS from Muslim
sisters
um talking about the lack of romance
from their husbands lack of you know
dating whatever we call now and I think
a lot of men neglect this part of the
Sunnah of how the prophet Muhammad
sallam was really
romantic to his wives you know obviously
it wasn't what we see today is obviously
different but you know I think a lot of
men are lacking and women are suffering
at home because they're just like
feeling neglected feeling ignored like
you said not complementary
um and
they feel bored with their partner and
that that's a big problem it's dangerous
you know and it is dangerous because if
your wife is continually saying she
wants your attention she wants your
attention she wants your attention and
you are ignoring that that complaint
ignoring that outcry
like you said eventually she may leave
or eventually she may go elsewhere
but it is very important to to not
neglect that and I think people really
make marriage like uh it is serious but
they make their marriage so serious like
marriage is supposed to be a Vibe you're
supposed to have fun with your husband
you're supposed to like talk laugh you
know it's supposed to be fun you know
when it it shouldn't feel like a janeza
when you get married that's it it's
doomsday seriousness like wake up sleep
cook clean like no life is dynamic it's
supposed to have you know
a younger person
literally so you can play around with
very correct he said oh I'm married and
for such reason the professor said fair
enough but the point is is that idea of
being played for was is mentioned then
by the prophet himself back you know
because there's gonna be a time for fun
and jokes and having a good time as well
like Handler this guy came uh sahabi
came to the prophet sallam he said look
I'm I'm always when I'm in when I'm in a
Masjid I'm very serious because I'm very
serious and I'm doing iPad I'm doing all
this kind of things but when I go home
I'm joking around I'm having a good time
I'm laughing around or whatever because
I feel like a hypocrite the prophet saws
he replied to me says look
he says one hour of this and one out of
that in other words because life can't
be all this it's not this is all serious
you know what I mean so it's of course
subhanallah Islam is always about
balance you see with two extremes too
much or not enough of the same thing
attention exactly it could be it could
be lethal to the marriage yeah it's true
it's all was about balance
so as men that are watching this
um so you said one of the things is did
you say romance a fiction or something
like that Romance just the husband being
romantic it wouldn't hurt you like I
know some women who literally have never
received not one flower from their
husband can I really can I can I just
actually some women are like suffering
I've had DMS and I'm shocked wow can I
add on to that because I think it's a
priority issue I think that
um most men just think that if they're
providing financially then everything
else is not really important but if you
look at female nature we are attention
Seekers we like attention we like our
man you know sometimes yeah exactly
sometimes we just call for no reason
just to hear that we we gain attention
and you know the guys putting us as a
priority I just on the way up here now
my uncle Francis I think his name was
really good guy and he's 62 and he was
giving me some information about how the
younger guys are failing at their
marriages because they're working too
much and he said a lot wives are saying
you're never home and need help with the
kids
um I just want to sit down with you I
just want to talk and a lot of them are
saying well why are you complaining I'm
working
and that's why I say it's a priority
issue like and that's why in the
beginning I said a good man in my
opinion a good husband is when he shows
up when he needs to in practical sense
like the theory here you can say he
needs to be doing this islamically and
stuff like that but in Practical when it
comes to their experience a lot of the
guys are not showing up true you know
the wives are complaining two buttons
that's why and the priority issue is
it's not just about working working
making money if we're talking about on
the basis of a good husband it's not
just about working making money it's
also about okay sometimes take that time
off and just spend a little bit of time
with your wife some women are just
content with that no no but you know
your husband just working like a horse
yes and and not you know coming home and
I think that's wrong it's miserable
Mercy for your husband as well
sit there and enjoy the benefits of your
husband and and exactly care that and
it's not resting not care that he's not
you know eating food proper complete
that's wrong as well yeah you know it's
true what since the dolphin said as well
but we need to create a balance because
we talked about gratitude and it's very
important yeah and Allah says in the
Quran that if you're grateful I will
impress you and for some odd reason
everyone that reads Ayah talks about
like if you're grateful Allah will give
you more money like that because Allah
doesn't specify unless if you're
grateful I'll increase you increase you
in what can it not be increase you in
gratitude more that you become more
happy yeah so the the thing is this
though like if these men if it's a man
who's just obsessed with money money
money money money yeah that's different
but if a man is working you need to
understand the prophet how many people
said if I was to tell anybody to do such
that to anyone it will be the woman to
the husband why the responsibilities on
our shoulder is so atheim it's so big
we're the head we're going to be
questioning about a household
we're going out there and providing all
kinds of stuff happen bro I know
Brothers before getting stabbed getting
robbed left at Center so when we come
home and the wife is like yeah but why
didn't you get me and it's like it's
like a knife bro it's like wow like I'm
going it's as if you are totally blind
to everything that I do and your friend
that you spoke to your excuse me your
dumb friend that you spoke to no no let
me be honest because they don't share
things that destroy the marriage yet oh
and my husband got me flowers did he get
you any yeah or something very true one
second maybe you didn't get flour he's
doing something bigger than flour yeah
maybe this dumb friend your husband's
God knows doing what else he maybe gets
you flowers but God knows what else he's
doing yeah okay uh besides flowers so
the point is this no no let's be real
here so the point is to come home and
have your wife just be like you know
what
was the last time you got me flowers two
years ago okay
isn't it every day that this man
provides for this house isn't every day
when a thief breaks down uh breaks the
house down I'm gonna be telling him to
go isn't it he's the same man well if
our country gets attacked he's going to
war so these elements are there why and
it comes back to gratitude If Only They
saw it and they said actually look at
all these things this man does we're
talking about a flower 40 pound flour
yeah
but it's because women see where men
Place their oh I see what they come from
where men Place their importance so if
if a man in two years hasn't bought you
flowers I was thinking about this I'm a
very methodical man I don't know if many
people know but I renewable I'm sorry no
no I'll come to it but I was gonna say
that
I spent from when I was about 17 years
old yeah I I'm quite
um methodical when it comes to time
I look at how long I spend
I started calculating how long obviously
I've been married for 11 years myself
because I'm not I'm not far off but I
started realizing how what's the what's
that
I've started to look at it and put this
way how long do I stay in the house what
becomes problematic for me and for the
other person how long does it so I've
been playing around with this for a long
time right what's the average and what
I've not nobody got exclude sleep and
other things as well no no let's just
have a disabled argument right
you've got to find your own balance
there's no answer there's no I can tell
you like be 18 hours in the house or 15
or per week or whatever out of 168. I'm
saying you've got 150 hours in a week
you gotta find your balance but what I
realized is the power of and this is
going to sound very cliche but quality
time like you can you can actually spend
five hours or five to ten hours but it's
proper quality you're taking her hair
there everywhere this and that she
shocked you that you know you know the
the kind of experience you're giving her
and the kids and whoever the whole way
is better than like double the time but
you're just sitting around watching
something
you know and there's and there's and
there's evidence for this because Helen
Fisher was the expert in love Yeah
Anthropologist and she's um she said
that when when my students come to me
and they ask me how to increase the love
of the relationship yeah going back to
dopamine
go and do something like adventures
together
yeah so you take the woman so I'm
sounding very like crude here very fast
take your yeah spontaneous King here so
you take sometimes I try and be so
spontaneous that even I don't know what
I'm gonna do
it's not honestly I think what I'm gonna
do now let's just do something boom
let's go here let's go just like that
and then it shocks everyone and then
she's like she comes back and she'll be
okay for that two three weeks because
you've done that kind of thing so
quality time is very important
physical and we can't really talk about
the sisters in front of us I can go into
we can have a whole discussion about the
intimate yeah we should do this but I'm
just saying that that's very important
and the dean has a big emphasis on that
the Hadith that you mentioned about yeah
you know the majority of women have been
a Hellfire because of like from last
year and so on there's a lot of
discussion about the Hadith
yeah yeah so what I'm saying is it's a
very famous Hadith by mentioned Muslim
that majority because they are angry
with their husbands right
I actually came across
um something from a guy called as a big
scholar he wrote mushkil Hadith like a
big Hadith collection and he was right
in the 20th century in the beginning of
20th century
and he he was doing Hadith and he said
that nowadays his view I'm not saying
this correct or not he's saying that
that applied to the woman at the time of
the Prophet Muhammad
this is what he said yeah he said that
that applied to those women he goes now
men are more ungrateful than women he
said now you'll find that if a man has a
terminal illness a woman is more likely
to be with him and stay stay with him
then a man is gonna go and do his own
thing I'm just saying whether or not
this is true it's interesting point but
the idea of course for last year is not
or being ungrateful is not something
that's gender specific and I'm not
trying to be whatever it is actually a
man can be like that as well that's a
spiritual disease so in gratitude is
something which permeates both male and
female
you know what I mean so that's why there
has to be a culture and I like what you
said in the beginning because that's a
good cultural gratitude I try and create
that with my children with my wife
whatever yeah I think it's trying to
create a culture of gratitude both sides
yeah you know what I mean I'm reminding
one another like so like sometimes I
would just like you know I'll sit down
with my wife and I'll just be like look
at the blessings we have like just just
let's just let's just go through it like
go to the the fridge of apple juice
orange juice water bro it's a big deal
to me what like people that feel
entitled to that so what it's just
orange juice but what are you talking
about Bros the forget that forget
having induced the fact that I have the
ability to taste it the fact that it is
good for me because there was you know
Junaid went to see here yeah Junaid was
somebody who's a multi is a billionaire
he owns half of Kingston yeah the the
only thing that God can eat is
vegetables do you know that really with
relation to what you your sisters were
mentioning about
um romance and something like flowers
for example you'll find that a lot of
men today
they are feeling um
unworthy inadequate
um their self-esteem is attacked daily
and unfortunately actually I'm slowly
starting to change my stance on Andrew
say even I love Andrew Tate for the sake
of Allah I've even made the off him and
things of that nature
overall I think that he's been fantastic
for Islam
um but I'm even starting to have some
issues with his message because brothers
who are working and who he would call
and would describe as broke he's like
they would fit in the Brokey category
um
men are consuming this content but they
know their wives are also consuming the
same content
so what's happening is because men are
feeling inadequate they're placing a lot
of emphasis on things like boost their
self-esteem
and that's why they're working so hard
because giving you a flower does not do
anything for their self-esteem but
seeing more money in their account for
example from their Uber that they did
that week that does something for their
self-esteem that's something that they
thought their wives places more value
um in that how much money they have and
makes them feel better about themselves
so that's that's I firmly believe that
that's a lot of the psychology behind
why men are actually being neglectful in
a romance side because they feel like
they don't deserve to be romantic I need
I'm not happy where I am I need to get
to X Y and Z so that I feel good about
myself and this ties in person with what
Muhammad hijab mentioned about this this
quality of
emotional Independence essentially I
think the Hadith you might be referring
to is it is when you mentioned about
also about the nobility of the Believers
in standing in the night that's the
advice that jabriel Islam gave to the
prophet salallahu I've got that on my
Instagram because I think that that
statement is just is is different level
from amongst the advices that he gave
him was five one is that love who you
wrote but know that one day you will
leave them
um you might I can't remember that I
love you you all know that you love
whoever you want but know that one day
you leave them live as you wish but I
know that one day you you will die the
nobility of the believer is in standing
in the night in prayer yes and um what
leads to his or her honor is in being
free from the need of people emotionally
physically financially you see men who
are confident in themselves this is one
of the things I should have mentioned
before when I speak about what a man
needs and unfortunately Allah Brothers
don't have it is they don't have a
strong self-image psychology they don't
have a firm image of who they are who
they want to be they don't know about
the sahaba they don't have anything
solid to to stick to yeah like imagine
like a spare going up like this and it's
just and that spear is your inspiration
that's your Ali that's yours that's your
prophet salallahu and you like stick to
it they don't really have that so
they're all over the place
they're trying to kill they're trying to
cling to something but they don't have
something solid so clingy but however if
they was a person who had a certain
self-image psychology they knew who they
was they was confident in themselves
their self-esteem was pretty solid yeah
they would feel okay to not have
that so much and they would be able to
open their minds up to their to their
wife's emotions be like okay yeah let me
get her a rose yeah because he's
confident within himself well a lot of
men are chasing because they don't feel
good about it you know what I believe
and and then very often unfortunately is
all I do have to add
women will sometimes complain about
certain things with relation to finances
so they feel like they can't even do it
even more they there's that there's that
pressure as well maybe if a wife was
letting her husband know that she's so
happy with the little that he has or
them whatever he has
expectations
I know of two marriages two marriages
one more specifically that I've ended
due to the husband doing too much work
one of them his wife was in Egypt and
his family was there
um and he would come and go but he would
spend four months here and one month
there because he wants to be a
particular person he wants to feel that
way about himself and another who did
the same thing and the marriage ended
and they're not happy about it but
they're working because when I went to
Dubai like a lot of the the taxi drivers
they're from like you know these
countries and well like if you look at
it like I know we're talking about how
to be a good Muslim husband but if you
think about it bro these men are without
their wives
and then you're working providing it's
like the sacrifice it does but again the
topic is but it's not necessary
exactly it's not necessary what do you
mean by that because the thing is if
there was job opportunities they would
not be going are you if you're telling
me he's going there tonight it's extreme
no no if it's like I want an extra I
need more money then of course there's
room on yourself and your wife
um but yeah on this um topic I mean
they're spoken a lot it's getting that
okay like we we're speaking of you know
I completely agree with what jibril was
saying in regards to you know
um The Red Pill ideologies and that's
what I said in the last episode about
our youth and our men and boys need to
stick to the Sunnah the Quran the sahaba
to have that inspiration from them
rather than these red pill people
because you're it is not the same we we
get our guidance and everything from
Islam and your masculinity and
confidence will all come from Islam the
women need to be careful of it as well I
even had a conversation a sister was I
was trying to put someone together an
afghan that I knew and another Afghan
and the sister said you know I need to
get me like an Andrew Tate and she's
like
not a supermodel what she's talking
about
but this is the thing we don't quantify
ourselves with that sort of thing at the
end of the day uh I'm not being funny
but the prophet Muhammad preferred to be
with the poor yes that's what I'm saying
if we follow uh the Sunnah and stuff and
I find myself sometimes being ungrateful
but I have to remind myself it's a
continual battle that we have to
continue to remind ourselves we have to
humble myself I mean to to admit openly
I find myself being grateful as well
just yesterday I was thinking about you
know I'm thinking like I'm quite
ungrateful but the fact that you have
that impulse that self-imples that you
can check yourself that's actually the
it's good because if he was alluded to
the fact that's where you have a real
problem yeah a lot of people are men and
women are deluded to the fact that they
have a they have a problem with
gratitude and you know what is is that
you'll find it a lot in what would seem
to be from the outside insecure people
and I'll tell you what I mean by that if
someone is insecure
insecure means they're not secure in
what they have right for example
they may be insecure about their looks a
man and a woman let's say it affects
women disproportionately because of the
modern age or whatever
a man might be very insecure about his
finances and insecure insecure and
secure I think you can't really be fully
insecure without being partly ungrateful
I'll tell you why because
for you to say that you know
you need to know that which is admission
that the nyama is there so for example
if you can't even admit that you have
certain characteristics that physical
characteristics and then or you've been
given like for example certain finances
or certain position in life
then your insecurity is actually
blameworthy from an Islamic perspective
because there's a partial negation of
the name of Allah how can you be so
insecure like a lot of people look in
the mirror they think it's humbleness
it's not humbleness when you say look
I'm very ugly person I don't even
consider myself to be so nice look at
this I'm not I've got this and that I've
got these issues whatever
then you don't know the worth of what
you've been given you've got body
dysmorphia like that's the big thing
that is for this movie obviously a part
of that is you're not grateful for what
you actually have like there's there's
men and women of all types of shapes
sizes and ages yeah and there's a market
for each like you were talking about
five foot I don't know five foot one
yeah there's a market five for one woman
yeah you know I mean I know I know
friends of mine who are very interested
in small petite like five foot one women
and I know friends of mine who are
actually interested and they cannot
handle that at all there's no chance
it'll be over five for one woman in fact
they want quite a big woman and there's
a massive market for that you know what
I'm saying so people need to know that
well you have it might you might not
think
it's a blessing but it's a blessing to
someone yeah well let's
do not wish what you what the other one
has you know
Allah has given something to everyone
and and insecurity is a big issue of
marriages but the solution to insecurity
is gratitude actually
and that goes back to what you were
saying in the beginning sorry can I make
a point actually just on the that point
the other day I went to go I think this
is very important for men to deal with
that issue actually I went with my mom
to visit my dad's grave
and I think that is so important for
everyone to to do regularly if they can
go and visit the dead because you'll
realize that actually that is was
promised and there's no difference
between who is poor who is Rich who was
young who was old inevitably that's
where we're going to end up so
realistically what are we actually
chasing for what are we dying for in
this Dunya it doesn't matter you know my
mom is looking at her husband in the
grave there's no five foot one five foot
six nothing you know he's gone to his
creator so I think we need to Humble
ourselves to that level to realize
actually
what is this
self-worthy should be a lot of humility
yeah I was just going to say it's also
about you know
adapting and making it easy for your
husband so if he's going out to work and
be a provider and working really long
hours and you're thinking oh I haven't
got my rose this year yet then you've
got to adapt yourself and think okay
well you know realistically what you
know what might be going through his
head that has made him forget well he's
working all the time so maybe you know
communication is a very important factor
in a successful marriage so you could
you know lightly communicate it but also
don't have expectations are unrealistic
based on his hard work for the family
and for you so that's one point but also
as well I think you know because of a
lot of the sisters and a lot of the
marriages these days the wives are also
working so I think there's that Dynamic
to the relationship where you know you
know some wise feel that their husbands
are not being that grateful so it works
both ways because especially if she's
also trying to fulfill her you know what
she is you know role in the house and
she's working full time and then coming
home and thinking I'm trying to be a
good wife so I'm gonna you know make it
easy for my husband and my family my
kids then there's that element as well
so the expectation obviously is going to
be the very minimum but perhaps a bit
more because she feels like maybe you
know I'm going above and beyond as well
so it's you've got to assess the
situation and you've got to adapt to all
in my opinion you're not you're not
watching the process no matter and it
all goes better you know when we talk
about tow Heat
people have the specific tahitis I go
and pray Salah and I say Allah is one
that's my tawheed
you cannot be so far away that's that's
a part of tawheed
if you want to give the rights of your
wife you first give the right of Allah
because bro when you fix your relation
with Allah from the get-go if you're a
man of taqwa you're a man who praises
Salah you are good conscious how do you
think you're going to be towards your
wife
do you get it so people worked the other
way around that year I need to go to a
marriage caution they're going how can I
be what do women like and this time
forget all this nonsense yeah we know
this as well but if you have a
relationship with Allah
Aqua you know when it comes to your eyes
what you listen to what you speak where
you walk to Aki you are basically when
you fix that you are fixing yeah you're
basically becoming the dream husband in
your wife's eyes and if she did the same
that is what I'm talking about where you
you are conscious because then you know
that you wouldn't want to violate her
rights because one of the things Islam
emphasizes on is the hack of someone
else that's what the seller would say we
would stand in front of Allah with 70
sins between us and him but not with
somebody that was wrong so much so the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him would
refuse burial of an individual who owed
debt why the hack of individuals what
about the half of your wife whatever you
are oppressing and and I hear stories
bro where men are oppressing their wives
to a level forget the base of art bro at
least making her work for his lifestyle
with the second or third wife whatever
this is a reality that's happening bro
online you have have mercy well like
simple stuff like for example bro you're
going what's your wife's favorite drink
cranberry on the way I'm gonna get crime
but would you know how much you mean for
the fact that you thought about it bro
it's simple one pound fifty or two pound
whatever it's something so simple
arguments say you're welcome to set my
feet are home how many men will do this
come up your feet massage
let me be honest people have this
perception you know what I want to give
my wife a feet massage yeah where's the
what is it look coconut oil is it yeah
choose the oil no problem yet why not
this is where the red pill and this that
lavender yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
make sure it's organic yeah so so the
point is what do not feel that you're
less of a man when you do this stuff
especially coming from this filth red
pill that no my wife no actually have
mercy man this is your wife and the men
who follow red pill have like hardcore
they're the most insecure yes
please it's crazy can I say something
can I say something I think we're
talking a lot here and it is quite
surface I think we need to understand
human behavior and when it comes to
human behavior that's what you're here
we adapt very quickly to our
surroundings environments and what we
expose to and unfortunately we do not
have those so-called influences that we
can look up to today as Role Models so
that we can actually go into the right
path because the thing is let me tell
you no you're not following me uh
probably their sister yeah it could be I
took a variety of stuff yeah well and
recently I've been heavily emphasizing
on this stuff as well but the thing is
the reason why is because let me tell
you something here I don't want to we
did a segment here
no self-esteal of men that don't even
have the kind of body that they may have
no no but the thing is they should get
top I'm so sorry Amanda sleeping on the
sofa the point is I don't want to be an
irresponsible public figure you know why
because I don't want to go and say oh me
and my wife look where we're going look
no no I'm so sorry you know why because
that is I don't mean that I don't mean
that what do you mean on a personal
level yeah like for me I just know in
order for me like how are you saying to
get closer to Allah to have fear yeah
unfortunately people don't understand
that psychology does go in with Islam we
just don't talk about it it is only the
science the psychology is to be mindful
and to practice when you practice that
brings that reminder for gratefulness
and contentmentness and it reminds you
as your rights and everything else that
you need to do we don't have that
routine we don't have that way of being
you can we leave the house without
reading Surah Yasin or a page of Quran
every day for the last how many years I
have to wake up whatever time I have to
for you know fedger but no people will
pick on you know how I look but at the
end
that are more important and it's also
obligatory and it changes my personality
character and how I see things and I
think when I'm coaching I coach more
backgrounds all parts of you know the
world and whatever it is I'm this you
know relationship coach
who has over 4 million subscribers and I
get a lot of people coming to me from
all different backgrounds so it's not my
personal experience it is from a variety
of things people get triggered when I
speak but I'm not speaking for my
personal experience it's because I'm
hearing to hundreds and thousands of
women and men with these issues and for
me especially when I'm coaching Muslims
I'm like check yourself what is it that
you're doing don't tell me the
terminology how is that showing up for
you in your lifestyle when you're saying
you are doing what you're doing how is
that showing up for you when you are
practicing in your daily life because
it's not just a lot it's in between your
Salah that it has to actually show up I
think that we're not doing that and we
don't have the real influence out there
first thing can you give me the Nasir
that you said that I'm not doing much of
so I can work on that number two no no
no no no no there's not enough to mean
it's if you believe that as a social
public figure I'm lacking on something I
would like to work on that so it's
totally fine number two uh you mentioned
a website I I don't I'm gonna you can
cut that out yes well you know what
you're doing I I trust you welcome to
doing it martial God bless you but uh
yeah I would just for that just for that
reason sorry I'm trying to make that one
in Charlotte but can you just tell me
when you were saying that can you tell
me personally what do you mean like you
know you said I always talk about but
what is it that I can imagine because I
think that people are not showing the
struggles of life and what actually
helps them through that struggle and for
me it is actually you know the striving
and going through the challenge and
adversity not just the outcome but the
journey and that journey is really you
know being in that sort of adversity and
Challenge and then saying you know what
it is about trust it is about okay in in
Islam it's about you know it's like you
know having tawaku but in in Psychology
it's having the Law of Attraction and
manifestation okay we can translate that
if we wanted to but at the same time
we're not talking about these sort of
psychological things that we have to do
as humans every day in our lives to
check ourselves it's not about oh we
have to understand a man and a woman it
will come naturally when you are seeking
you know the sort of Direction you know
the right part and that takes practice
every day for an individual then you
will be you know I don't actually look
for things it comes to me when I'm
having a tour subhanallah I open my page
social media is on my side where an
article will come up because I'm going
to be doing a show and it actually comes
to me because I'm seeking it we're not
seeking it we're not actually practicing
our faith we don't even understand our
faith we know we know all the rules but
we're not actually doing the little
things like I said how many people and
this is Ramadan or certain times of the
year that we will do this we need to
take more interest in that we need to
emphasize more on Quran and and you know
that is my power and that is my
protection we don't talk about Islam in
that way she she asked she she's
is very true what she's saying because
for for for marriage to be preserved
amongst like all of the fitness and the
mess out outside we need the aid of our
last final entire life 100 and and I
think like to use a psychology terminal
like Maslow's hierarchy of needs and the
top of that being you know fulfilling uh
your potential a lot a lot of issues
with with men and when they make
mistakes and become bad husbands there's
usually something going on within
themselves they're not satisfied with
and they they feel like they're not
fulfilling their potential whether it's
religiously whether it's done your eyes
and they become agitated individuals
they become
um
um individuals who seek validation or
self-esteem from somewhere else usually
as women as well that's when the silly
little DMS come and this that and the
other thing and it's like if I'm a man
who's busy you know the men from the
past they were really they were gold
they had a mission they lived the lives
of purpose yes like we and that's
something I feel like we don't really
live a life of purpose yes yes providing
for your family is purposeful but you
know like it's deeper like we men our
mission is
the focus was given to pleasing Allah
Our Lives will change we do not do that
but I'm sorry as men we don't do that
bro sisters as well they don't but our
focus is not pleasing Allah bro our
focus is not oh I miss Salah bro you
should be crying you should be well you
should
I'll make you forget yourself only in my
remembrance to Hearts find peace bro
Allah is telling you you are programmed
to find happiness in him what do we do
we go and Chase
I think that going back to I think
there's a good point that you made about
like objectives and Mission and that's a
very recommended important key term
because it relates back to the question
at hand which is like what does it take
to be a good Muslim husband but I think
that's one of the key ingredients in
fact in fact one of the things I
probably found my son right yeah you had
wallet I tell him look yeah I said to
him
you need to have your own objectives and
you have your own mission right
obviously at the heart of it is
yeah so protect yourself and your family
from the Hellfire for us
the human beings have to worship me
right now that's how you manifest that
and what you said that really was is a
good point about potential Emmanuel Kant
who seems like one of the biggest
philosophers in nursing Enlightenment
history yeah he said one of the biggest
sins obviously for us is not like this
but it's an interesting way he put it
it's for a person not to explore their
potential yeah because if everyone in
society does that he said then you
wouldn't get Innovation you wouldn't get
technology you wouldn't get science you
wouldn't get whatever yeah and that
applies to both husband and wife and
I'll be honest with you I've noticed
through like marriage and other things
and not just on my own marriage not a
counselor but I've seen it from other
Americans as well is that you've got to
appreciate that your wife is an
individual with a lot more to offer than
just
and why is duties now if she feels like
she's harboring potential that she could
otherwise manifest with you not in the
picture that's actually quite dangerous
as well so you've got to give her an
outlet of that that because I feel like
we're living in an age now
where everyone is comparing everything
with everyone else at a level that's
never happened at all now I'm not saying
that okay we can easily say don't
compare
okay okay that's fine don't compare
we I believe so we are social creatures
but we also comparative creatures we are
going to compare it's going to happen
man's gonna compare with other minor
one's going to compel a woman
so yeah there needs to be an aspect of
gratitude to curb that but also there
needs to be an aspect of all right
there's an outlet here as well because
we talk about the man's needs for the
second wife right the woman also has
needs like that she feels like for
example one thing I've noticed is when a
woman goes to the beach and she sees all
these people like for example in bikini
or the or the park or something like
that she sees women get very upset at
the fact a lot of them do Muslim women
wait a minute I don't get to do that do
you know I don't get the experience of
going into the sea or going to the
swimming pool there's a lot of things
I'm restricted from doing
and there is a theory in Psychology
let's go to the sea but no no but not in
the same way I'm saying that I cannot
remember it's called replacement Theory
or I think replacement Theory the idea
that if you tell someone not to do
something too much that it can actually
have the opposite and that's why reverse
psychology comes in and this is
interesting because the Quran actually
alludes to this
human being is transgressive so they
cannot just be top top down and you
don't do this don't do this don't do
this with life you need to give her some
out you really do need to give Outlets
because if you don't give her those
Outlets one day it can actually explode
into something quite dangerous you know
and this Outlook seems to be out okay
like creative Outlets if if your wife is
you gotta see what she's like you've got
to see you gotta see what your keys of
your wife is you've got to see a
creative person what does she like to do
and then try and find an Islamic Avenue
where she can actually do those things
so she doesn't feel like she's always
suppressing something together
I'm sorry
I am so sorry that is if you disagree
and you have one and a half minutes
sorry I had no choice
I have a question for the guys like
everyone's had really mature outlooks on
how to be a good husband right but how
much of that has to do with your age
because I think the younger the guy is
the more immature he's going to be and
the older he is is the more mature he's
gonna
do you feel like that has something to
do with the age the way you look at it
as a man okay so the question is
31 I'm almost 35 so how much
yeah yeah I don't think I don't think
alhamdulillah there's no alcohol pork
alcohol pork should see my peers
um yeah from school but um I was gonna
say uh yeah I'm not gonna lie they look
so much yeah
the question is age player um
100 100 personally I don't think it does
why not because
you know what you are going to school
sorry I've got there's two brothers I've
got in front of my eyes okay and I
respect them so much and they're young
yeah and I just want to shout out
because I'm gonna say
and they're young brothers and uh then I
say they're young they early 20s mid-20s
you know
um and their terabia was different
homeschooled that's it yeah
but I feel like most men if they're
going to be real and accountable most of
them do turn around and say I started to
mature around 35 or 33 or after 27 and
stuff like that so I'm just saying
because you know like for example the
average age of marriage I think for for
the for the dominant population this
country is like 28 for a woman and 32 or
something like that for a man yeah 20
for example yeah so I mean the Muslim
Community is completely different in
terms of like where it starts to get
married because of Xena and all that
kind of stuff and familial person yes
yes so if like for example if
I don't know to what extent is it to
what you were saying is Right experience
it's like I've been driving a car for 15
years right yeah because I got the
license when I was 17 yeah or something
like that yeah so I've been driving for
I don't know 14 years something like
that now let's say for example you get a
person my age who's just got the license
for two years now I've had way more
driving experience than he does yeah
yeah does marriage work in a similar way
because like I've got wait so someone
just got married for two years but he's
45 yeah he's gonna have to be asking me
for advice yeah absolutely I agree his
age
situation I agree I would say because me
and my husband also got married at 22
23. oh well I'm not married young and I
would say although we were mature at
that age we have matured that's what I
mean with the experience of being
married but it has to be within it yes
yes when you have certain values then
they grow but if you don't have the
values initially then those are the
things that will make you in a
particular way where you might find them
irresponsible or not responsible because
I speak to a lot of young men and to be
honest I actually do admire because
today everything is so open they don't
have an excuse not to know certain
things and they have much more wisdom
than even our parents as much as they
need to teach us I think they're much
more open to knowledge and even what is
happening in the world so I really don't
understand I'll ask you a question I'm
actually you're curious all right
quickly because we're running what if a
man has been in multiple relationships
at the same time is he more experienced
love for example is it the fact that I'm
just saying like excuse me for example
like say for instance
I don't know like in general a marriage
as a for example if he's this guy has
been married let's say to two women four
certain amount of three oh but let's
just say for the sake of argument who's
more experienced a Muslim man would be
married for let's just say three years
to three women or a Muslim man that's
been married to one woman for 10 years I
don't know it's three no no it depends
number three if they can manage all
three that's quite mature if they can
manage for a long term that's also
mature so we also have to break it down
because we're very generalizing about a
lot of these things you have to be quite
specific and focused mature in what way
mature in actually bringing a house or
maturing emotional intelligence immature
you know all of this kind of things
there's so many different characters I
think we're coming is about
understanding how to be with a woman or
how to deal with a woman
it's true but we're talking about I
think maybe because of my angle where
it's a man who has had a jahilia and has
whatever it may be well there's
something to be proud of it should be
ashamed though but but the reality the
reality is this bro of course it does
the reality is this though of course the
way he operates with women he has an
Insight
yes
in The Finnish article we might not
either most he doesn't need to be the
most mature but you need to but you guys
need to mature together
and it is because the thing is the thing
is it's it's yeah the thing is it's like
that because the thing is at the end of
the day for a man when he had like when
he's with he's with a woman you're
married or not married
Etc you need to understand that that
works in so many advantages for him
number one he becomes less desperate
because you need to understand and with
women women psychology is that basically
when he when you're with a woman it will
sit in his jacket here bro you you have
no girlfriend you have no girlfriend
I'll tell you you have no girlfriend for
example yeah nobody wants to know you
the moment you get a girlfriend
argument's sake yeah all these girls are
now interested in it yeah
is it my hair is it my beard remember
yes now because what is it's called sign
now he's like okay she's with him
there's a reason number two woman woman
of competition within each other and
number three he works in advance of a
man how because when he is just just to
give context when he is being intimate
with her he is less desperate that worst
Advantage when he is yes because now
he's he has a leverage because he's not
desperate when a man doesn't have anyone
in his life his he's seeking he's
seeking and he's desperate but when he
has a thank you that's true thank you so
when a man has someone who's into
apartment first wife for example if he
has a first wife you'll see the second
third fourth they just come and you know
why because women are within their
nature like that we're going to talk
about that and this is the doctor but we
have to run out of time we've got a few
more topics
um inshallah we're going to be touching
on this topic
um until next time brothers sisters from
the picture of me Allah bless you guys
uh this is send this to your husband
send this to your son send it to your
brothers let us do whoever you want to
send inshallah um because at the end of
the day this is an important topic and
for those men who are oppressing their
wives we ask you to feel Allah
and Allah it's you will be questioned
under their judgment it is not uh small
you know oppressing them not giving them
the rights affection and love you know
till next time
whoever builds a Masjid from the sake of
Allah Allah will build for him a similar
house in Jannah on that day where Allah
tells us that our books will be given
and every little active weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you know
what a lucky person which righteous
person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allow people to
pray you built a Masjid I never had the
money to build a master to Allah
it helped gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if
only it now guys and do not delay and
and share the video for extra Rewards
foreign
[Music]